is that rationalism thesis also known as
the secularization thesis or is that a
separate phenomenon no it is it's the
same
yeah it's the same so in that case as
far as i know in the western world
atheism is on the rise it's just in
other parts of the world where it's not
is that correct yes i i believe that's
correct
yeah so then in that case would that not
be a testament to the secularization
thesis because it's saying that in these
more enlightened i know that this is
eurocentric and and i'm going to get
canceled but i'm just i'm strong manning
for the sake okay
maybe the rationalists are more likely
to say this but in these more
enlightened societies that's where
atheism takes the foothold and it's more
of something that's akin to a religious
monarchy that the religions it's mainly
through dominance and so on so why does
the growth of global religion contradict
the uh secularization thesis
because to me it sounds like well in
this this thesis is saying that in the
spots where we hold the values of the
enlightenment and so on that's where
atheism should take hold all right i
think what you're talking about is a
movement called um where where
especially young people um they
basically say that they're not religious
but they might be spiritual but not
religious and these people are called
the nuns and they're called the nuts
they're not n-u-n-s they're
n-o-n-e-s
and they're called that because when
they
tick off the census
they put we have no religion so we have
what's your religion none right so
that's what makes them you know that's
why they're called the nuns okay so this
is definitely on the rise but the thing
about this is that to us in religious
studies it actually does not look
secular because those people engage in
yoga okay and they also believe in ufos
right and so when you scratch the
surface of belief in ufos you see like
you know transcendent beliefs or beliefs
and a transcendence of you know this um
this advanced tech is somehow salvific
right and things like that or on the
other hand it's very bad you know it's
like kind of evil or something like that
so you do see a lot of themes there that
appear to be religious like so i would
contest that the rise of the nuns is
actually a secularization
um
the rise of atheism i think that as you
know
i mean beliefs change
atheism is something that
um
you know i wouldn't ascribe it i
wouldn't say
atheists are de facto more rational than
religious people that's just not right
that's not true
so i wouldn't ascribe the rise of
atheism to the rise of
kind of rationality or something like
that because i know a lot of people who
are
not atheists
they're either agnostic or theists and
are very rational
so but i mean it's just not who i know
but it's also you know
um
these are generalizations that i think
require
a lot of we must we have to be really
careful when we're talking about that
but yeah i don't see that